marjorie 17 ans a été tuée à coups de
couteau aux alentours de 16h30 sur
l'esplanade centrale du quartier
marjorie a été tué par un jeune homme de
seulement 14 ans après avoir voulu
défendre sa soeur d'un harcèlement sur
les réseaux sociaux
moi cette histoire elle m'a bouleversé
tout le week-end je vous le dis vraiment
il a encore voilà je voulais absolument
qu'on en parle ce soir quelques minutes
après une altercation leur garçon s'est
rendu chez lui il a pris un couteau et
l'a poignardée froidement marjorie à
plusieurs reprises avant de prendre la
fuite
marjorie est décédé après avoir reçu un
coup de couteau en plein coeur c'est un
drame bien entendu pour toute la france
pour toute sa famille pour sa mère pour
ses soeurs qu'on a entendues dans un
instant sera donc avec l'avocat du jeune
homme qui a été mis en examen pour le
meurtre de marjorie adama kamara qui a
perdu son petit frère en 2011 à
garges-lès-gonesse décédé après
plusieurs coups de couteau sur une même
histoire
adama a passé plusieurs années en prison
après avoir voulu venger la mort de son
frère
il est désormais dans la prévention il
sera avec nous voilà il dit il a voulu
se faire justice lui même et ça c'est
cette pire qui puisse arriver mais
d'abord regarder ce petit sujet qui
résume ce qui s'est passé à
ivry-sur-seine vendredi dernier vraiment
on est tous très très très ému ce soir
et j'ai envie de savoir ce que va nous
dire
l'avocate ce jeune homme qui a été mis
en examen pour le meurtre de margerie
regarde la dispute a débuté sur les
réseaux sociaux
la soeur de la victime aurait reproché
aux suspects via un groupe snapshot
d'avoir mal parlé à d'autres filles de
ce même groupe
vendredi le suspect de 14 ans se dispute
avec marjorie va chercher un couteau de
cuisine puis poignardé la jeune fille de
17 ans au niveau du thorax
arrêtés quelques heures après le meurtre
le suspect de 14 ans est expliquée plus
longuement devant les enquêteurs
selon lui vendredi dernier ils jouent au
football à côté de chez lui lorsque
quatre personnes la victime
le frère et la soeur de la victime et
une autre personne de leur entourage
sont venus à sa rencontre
le groupe le pousse dans une impasse
pour qu'il s'explique sur les propos
tenus dans ce groupe stade chat en garde
à vue le suspect a affirmé avoir reçu
des coups de poing et des coups de pied
après cela il explique être rentré chez
lui afin de prendre ses affaires de
football pour se rendre à son
entraînement mais aussi un couteau de
cuisine
c'est en sortant de chez lui qu'il
croise de nouveau marjorie avec un
garçon et qui lui assène le coup de
couteau au cours de la dispute
mais il affirme avoir pris ce couteau
dans l'idée de se défendre faut-il
abaisser la majorité pénale à 15 ans
cette affaire est vraiment je vous dis
elle nous a tous bouleversés retourner
nous sommes avec m adrien gabo avocats
du jeune homme qui a été mis en examen
pour le meurtre de marjorie merci d'être
là adama kamara merci à damas militants
associatifs
voilà rappeur et anciens détenus ton
histoire elle est folle tôt en 2011
taton qui frères sada qui a été
poignardé à la gare de sarcelles
j'avais tiré il ya 2 heures du matin sur
son blog ce que tu as appris la nouvelle
c'est ça pourquoi il était poignardé en
fait jusqu'à aujourd'hui on sait même
pas la raison souvent les rixes on sait
même pas ça parle de quoi
mais malheureusement c'est comment ça
termine par des conséquences dramatiques
des familles détruites
moi quand j'ai perdu mon frère en 2011
hu est en train de dormir à deux heures
du mat on m'appelle on sonne à la maison
une glissade highmore sait comment ça ça
demande gilles à la gare j'arrive à la
gare bat souvent comme dans dans les
films quand on voit un drap blanc par
terre on sait que c'est fini
hélas l idée de vous venger comment ça
vous traversé l'esprit votre père il
vous dit soit de le faire on perd il dit
soit de le faire pendant des années j'ai
même eu une fait entre temps je me suis
dit peut-être que je vais continuer à
vivre faire comme si de rien n'était et
après on fait le fait de pas parler ni à
sa petite amie niasse et ses amis à ses
frères et soeurs ni à ses parents à un
moment donné on est rangée on parle même
pas un psychologue
vous savez qui avait fait ça ouais je le
savais c'étaient des amis du quartier
vraiment trois ans plus tard vous
décidez de passer à l'acte je passe à 1
tiré sur le frère du responsable et ses
amis sur place c'est ça ouais donc c'est
des personnes que vous connaissiez que
celle des personnes que je connaissais
des personnes avec qui j'ai grandi
c'est malheureux ils sont blessés
échappe à la mort c'est vrai c'est sans
être condamnée à huit ans de prison pour
tentative de meurtre c'est ça puis
libéré en juillet 2010 9 après avoir
effectué 70 % de votre père
aujourd'hui donc vous êtes père de
famille comme vous nous guidiez ont
multiplié les interventions pour faire
de la prévention dans les écoles de la
route et aux élèves votre histoire vous
avez également participé à la série
documentaire x sur france tv slash
l'histoire de margerie et elle vous
rappelle celle de votre petit frère
déjà pour commencer je soutiens vraiment
la marjorie sa maman qui est vraiment a
pris la parole dignement et je sais
assez à ces moments là c'est pas facile
de parler mais ils prennent quand même
la parole ils disent ce qu'ils sont en
train de vivre c'est horrible de perdre
une jeune fille ou perdants
freire ou perdre un enfant c'est
horrible et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
je me bats c'est pour éviter de voir ce
genre d'image de voir une maman pleurer
comme la mienne pleure encore ça fait
dix ans je me bats vraiment ce qu'on a
fait là le documentaire x c'est vraiment
nette à la rencontre des familles pour
avoir leurs témoignages vraiment pas ce
qu'on voit ce qui se passe à la télé les
agressions on va ya marqué en télémark
d'une rixe mais derrière on dit que
quand une personne toute une famille de
familles et toute une famille à mon
humeur derrière nous nous dira la
changer jusqu'à aujourd'hui
bien sûr voilà donc il ne reste quoi
après